what was it like returning to
middle-earth for The Hobbit and what can
people expect from your next two
journeys there well we've got we have to
go back for another five weeks in in May
to finish filming the other two films I
gathered from Peter Jackson he's
finished cutting the second film that's
basically done so it's I think it's the
battle sequences at the end of and of
the hobbit story that's are going to
take out the time what can they expect
well I'd be tempted to say more of the
same as that that the New Zealand in all
its glory
whole new range of different actors this
time 13 dwarves the new Hobbit and when
we get into part 2 and part 3 that
they'll be characters who don't appear
in the current Hobbit unexpected journey
view you would see Stephen Fry and a
wonderful Alf play by Lee pace and and
Luke Evans a wonderful romantic Welsh
actors with a large partner but bad so
there's lots more to go and people say
well how can you make such three long
movies out of one short but well because
Tolkien's sometimes refers to events in
a paragraph which in order for the
filmmakers to achieve cinematography
less cinematically you just need time
it's one advantage over writing a book
making film they can do it quicker and
cheaper but the story isn't expanded
it's just they're all they're theater
for you to look at and wonder you had a
tattoo didn't you for the Lord of the
Rings film was there anything similar to
celebrate the Hobbit series no this is a
slightly older crew than
than the fellowship and perhaps not as
adventurous day we did all get a ring to
celebrate it but not nothing permanent
no thank you
now of course you've returned to
middle-earth with The Hobbit and you're
also going to be turning to another
world don't need the x-men world with
Days of Future past we've got a little
while to wait for that film but what do
you hope we'll see in that I would
really who never quite know with x-men
it's some there are so many stories told
in the comics and and and time is not
linear the story goes backwards and
forwards and to the Future and then
comes back again and I suppose that
swing is going to be in this film
because there will be two Magneto's that
my younger my younger self Michael
Fassbender and the sames true Professor
X Jeff Beck avoid playing him many joke
whether we meet ourselves as but we were
young I don't know III haven't haven't
seen the finished script so it's Bryan
Singer directing so it'll be back to
there all the majesty of the first two
in the series do you think if you'd like
to face up to your younger self in the
form of Michael Fassbender if that did
happen you'd better watch out you tell
him now you've been in so many iconic
things over the years think of course
the Hobbit the Lord with the Rings we've
got the x-men Coronation Street one of
the things we love and there you lived
as well but also coming up this year
we've got the Doctor Who Christmas Day
special what's it like to be part of
that and also on the eve of the 50th
anniversary the doctor as well mm well
I've just been filming with Sylvester
McCoy who was Doctor Who number seven
who in another incarnation played the
fool in to my King Lear on stage I don't
have much to do people shouldn't get too
excited but my contribution but
and I shouldn't tell you what it is
because it's it would involve unraveling
some of the plot which is part of the
thrill of watching it but very nice to
be even peripherally connected with the
Doctor Who am I enjoy watching it have
you been a fan of the series and which
of the doctors have impressed you
particularly over the years no I haven't
been watching it over the years I don't
think I could name the mourner but Matt
Smith is got a wonderful quality to him
and as all doctor who's as all actors
he's dependent on the scripts and they
began Russell T Davies setting up a
whole concept which was very very clever
and persuasive but that's when
Christopher Eccleston was playing it
that's why it was known for a season so
I can remember Waris was saying who
directed the very first Doctor Who
telling me about it I said it was there
was sci-fi for kids and I diligently
watched the first episode I think the
Daleks probably appeared on it so I do
go I will along we're back with Doctor
Who but I haven't been a diligent fan
episode after episode I must say if you
were lucky enough to be able to get into
that TARDIS and it could take you
anywhere would you like to go anytime
anyplace
oh no I've been toothpaste well South
America but I can do that by going by
plane from that no I've no interest in
time travel I don't think I'm quite
enough to fascinate well in real life
and I think judging by what happens to
Doctor Who
time travel ain't worth the trouble it's
it's nothing but troubles it
you